so if you make a rubber of me it's gonna
be like I am real
I will taste it producer hi I'm ray you
probably see me in front of the camera
but today I will show you what's
happening in behind the scene today I'm
shooting with amazing candy artist candy
5 and right now it's 9 a.m. and I'm
going to start setting up are you ready
so it takes a lot to make a tasty video
I don't think people realize we are
doing everything by ourselves we do have
some support we have a food team we
sometimes bring in some assistants but
usually producer makes everything shoot
and edit everything so I will one-man
band but playing Orchestra sometimes she
takes a whole day especially when you
are directing talent and I can feel
today it's gonna be a long day not many
people know about this but I used to
work for ethical Center not the
merchandise shop we reconnected recently
and she was visiting the LA like this is
a great opportunity to shoot video with
her especially good Asian Pacific
Heritage Month is coming up I thought
while the shooter know how amazing skill
and decided to shoot video with her and
she agreed so she loves giving she likes
to make candy so she can make people
happy that is my favorite part of her I
set the camera in the place so I can
film their first candy of the day
[Music]
we are studying with a uni compa she's
also making money from Engel and cranes
she start taking a request she made
octopus and other animals because she
can make anything she uses Japanese
scissors and she is making a little cuts
it's only takes her a few cuts in order
to make a candy look like an animal it's
always amazing and it's always
fascinating what I notice what so and
she start making can be how face
completely changed it's almost like
actress on the stage when candy fiber
makes animal shape candy it happens
super quickly sheet so patience with me
because I asked her to make same animal
over and over in order to get there
great shot I don't shoot this kind of
video much so keep high in focus it's
the biggest challenge for me
[Music]
Charlie five and I both from Japan and
we communicate in Japanese and I don't
get to direct someone in Japanese often
directing her in Japanese is a little
bit easier for me because I can direct
her more precise so maybe three years
ago if somebody asked me what my role is
I feel like I don't have enough
confidence saying that I'm a producer or
I'm a director but this point I've shot
with migos but now I've done so many
videos made so many people and having
this high stake outside talent cost me
to be confident and forced me to get job
done I'm gonna lecture in tasty
producers secret I'm using flour
container so candy if I become
restaurant while she's making candy so
for me it's very easy to get a good
focus especially for this year it is
very important to get different angle of
the same candy so when we edit the video
become very smooth she's going to make
candy
it's been a while since I saw her making
candy but it never gets old it's so
magical it's so entertaining the shoe
party is over but we still have to
record the voiceover so we are moving
over to the recording booth so I can
interview can be 5 so county 5 wanted to
the interview in English because she
want to show that she can speak English
so she can get more business doing the
interview in second language it's very
difficult curds on back of your head you
have some fear of people maybe that
understand you or people who make fun of
your accent but our audience is very
supportive for me I'm so proud of her
because I've been there before so I felt
like I can give some advice to her like
don't worry they will love you no matter
what
I love featuring kind talented people
who make a difference in the world I am
so grateful she came today and I'm able
to shoot with her and show her talent to
our audience
for doing beauty shop it is easier just
doing by myself so I don't have any
pressure and I can take as much time I
need for this candy video it is
three-dimensional but I have a genius
idea I'm using lazy susans so I can show
all the angle of the candy she created
the styrofoam is way too big so it's not
rotating as I wanted so I decided to cut
it everyone around me start staring at
me in a weird way but I'm kept going
because I need that shot I do anything
for the shot I also came up this genius
idea
starting horrible as I'm ultramel so bad
so beauty shots are done and next I'm
going to support my candy five is very
generous and she made each of us as a
candy she made herself me Alex
Adam Annie and copy I told my friends
that I have a surprise gift for them
before I give them the candy I told them
to close their eyes oh I wish my friends
will be so surprised as I predicted but
I unfortunately pick those three who
doesn't have a lot of facial expression
for Kathy and Alex looks great I feel
like whenever you receive the candy five
candy we become child again that's the
magic of washi dad's I think the coolest
part of this job is connecting with the
audience I feel like I have friends all
over the world so it takes a special
kind of person to be a tasty producer
you have to have a lot of passion for
food video and editing before it gets
published I'm already thinking about my
next video idea and I turn around and do
that all over day
Oh
[Music]